portals into the heart of the earth
they burn
bottomless cauldrons fueled by an
ancient wrath
bubbling and boiling thousands of miles
beneath the surface
and just waiting to burst through
volcanoes are scattered across the
planet
about 1500 active volcanoes can be found
across the world though countless others
are on the ocean floor
most volcanoes whether on land or
underwater are located where tectonic
plates meet
in fact the ring of fire a path that
traces the boundaries between several
tectonic plates around the pacific ocean
contains about 75 percent of the
planet's volcanoes
there are several types of volcanoes
primarily classified by shape and size
major types include
stratovolcanoes which often appear as
tall steep mountains
shield volcanoes which are flatter and
dome-shaped
calderas which are large depressions in
the ground
and mid-ocean ridges which are
underwater chains of volcanic mountains
no matter their shape or size
all volcanoes emit gas and molten rock
the journey of these emissions begins
deep underground in the earth's core
the core which can burn as hot as the
surface of the sun transfers its heat to
the surrounding rocky mantle
in doing so
the heat melts some of the rock this
molten rock or magma is lighter than the
surrounding solid rock layer so it rises
through the mantle
the magma then escapes through vents in
the earth's crust causing volcanic
eruptions
[Music]
now above ground this magma is referred
to as lava and it can reach temperatures
of over 2000 degrees fahrenheit
in addition to lava volcanoes may erupt
with searing hot gas formed in the
mantle
in a phenomenon called pyroclastic flow
this gas combined with hot ash can race
down the sides of a volcano as fast as
100 miles per hour burning everything in
its path
[Music]
to measure and classify eruptions
scientists develop the volcanic
explosivity index or vei
it considers various factors such as the
volume of lava gas and other emissions
from the volcano along with the height
of the eruption cloud above the volcano
summit
[Music]
the vei scale begins at zero
each successive measurement increases
logarithmically meaning that each
magnitude is 10 times more powerful than
the one before it
the vei scale does not have an upper
limit but the most catastrophic
eruptions measured thus far are
categorized as vei8
these eruptions occurred thousands and
millions of years ago
the most destructive volcanic eruption
ever witnessed occurred in indonesia in
1815.
mount tambora a large stratovolcano
erupted with a vei measurement of seven
the blast caused earthquakes tsunamis
and pyroclastic flows that decimated the
land and took tens of thousands of
indonesian lives
the eruption even destroyed the top of
mount tambora itself turning the 13 000
foot tall mountain
into a 3
640 foot deep caldera
[Music]
while volcanoes are some of the most
destructive forces of nature they have
also helped make life on earth possible
volcanic ash provides nutrients to
nearby soil making the land fertile
and lava when it cools hardens into rock
and creates new landforms
with heat from the heart of the earth
volcanoes have helped terraform the
planet making it the rich
dynamic landscape
we see today
[Music]
you